the streets around dedan Park High
School remains sealed off this is now an
active crime scene as detectives piece
together the events here the school day
had just been ending pupils and parents
walking home when a silver Ford car
mounted the pavement and plowed into a
group of people a 12 year old boy was
critically injured and died in hospital
a short time later five others a 13 year
old boy - 15 year old boys and a 16 year
old girl were injured along with a 52
year old woman a massive hunt is now
underway to find the car and it's driver
who failed to stop we're releasing the
name of a man who we want to speak to in
connection with the investigation this
is a local man 51 year old Terry Glover
from Alton we've searched a number of
addresses this evening in an attempt to
find him and the searches for him a
silver Ford Ka with the registration LS
0 8 o K W are continuing I'd like to
make a direct please to mr. Garber if he
is watching or listening to this please
contact us we need to talk to you at st.
John's Church near the school a special
service has been held to pray for the
victims and their families as this
community tries to absorb the enormity
of events here I was shocked really a
you've ever expected this sort of thing
to happen in a community like Loudoun it
was a difficult difficult news to hear
my thoughts really are with all the
family involved and all the students at
Devlin Park are really struggling to
know how to feel this time it's a tough
time for the mall and my thoughts are
within the boy who died and the other
children injured we're all pupils at
Debden Park High I said as a tragic
event has happened and we're so sorry
for the for the people of the affected
and all the kids must be shocking for
everybody at this stage there is no
motivation for the terrible events here
police are trying to find the driver as
quickly as possible
in the meantime the public are being
warned to remain vigilant mark white Sky
News